We are all trying to preserve
the rich diversity of European countries
because if that diversity is suppressed,
we shall weaken Europe, not strengthen it.
The founders of the European Community
wanted to draw strength from that diversity.
They fully recognised the scale of the task,
but their aims were much more ambitious
than just a materialistic vision.
A European war was to be made not just unlikely
but unthinkable.
We have to strengthen the ability of Europeans
to act on a European basis
where the nature of a problem requires
a European response.
War has not been banished from the European continent;
I think particularly of the war-torn republics
of what used to be Yugoslavia.
The healing process symbolised by Strasbourg
remains badly needed elsewhere.
We have witnessed the triumph of democracy
and the demise of dictatorship in Central Europe.
With the collapse of the Berlin Wall,
the Iron Curtain has fallen.
Our task now is to tend and nurture the green shoots
of a democratic spring.
The Community is especially well-suited to this task.
New members are knocking at the door.
We should be confident of opening it to them.
We must ensure that the friendship and mutual respect
which we have built among ourselves
should extend more widely throughout our continent
and enrich our relations with the wider world.
It is a worthy ambition true to the conviction
and example of the founding fathers of the Community.